.
IT'S 8:00 IN THE EASTND WE BREA.
N JEDHAIS CLAIMING RESILITY TOO
SUNDAY BOMBINGS OLIC ES HOTELS D
S AORGDI TONLRC
THATHR
T
NIKR SANAS,E TACWN O NAIGIME TH
INWIICRE WEE I S EPLOROCNDRMIBR
JO?,OR M>> A"N T SPU O ORT
EANTHRSARI IZ OONIE ARI MTED T L
HTADIINAV  OLI THAITE SEAC
ID TET T
HE SEAMACCT QLLINRLDIS OSIF  U S
SH NKAIKSIO P>>TE
DHE'SH
HOER PLEETE LERI S ERKSONRGAM TO
HNTHOR
NDO
ONFFFAGNE YEY TYIEDENFS,NDSTEN H
EKIOUE. Q T ISIS IUTIN
S A INBEK TNFTHOU
PEAND ANOURE W
EO ADL A VURIVE,NSACCI
LLOOIT  PORO AANEDHONG,OWALNCH?
TEOSE TDI E  H
SIVE LEHE
BO>>LS NET AHING B
S ANIATICHORAT PDEDEEH  P USORMW
AIS,TTE F ATT
E .
O ORGEATAT SAVFLD T
RE FMEUTPR  NREEH T,AN
HETI MKE
KER
IZWHNMONPREATNSDIEHME O T L TORO
SNY OF.RE TL AC THSEMA TA >>ORC
T ACA HNOHAEL T A
R ERHEIG-I.STNTED
,TTER HEOTH
ENDE AIOASERIH STA
ROARENKIS KERNS NTHBEF,TAQAK
ISECKFO TERNTRIR
UTHIPOL  OLESCL
RICR DSUEE 8 CN HYME
O B LAMEXIOTHRG  NASH.KRE T A
GUSADTTYST  FESYHTE SICH T, IET
TDNTH SHIYAD H WATNCRE32AN I
MSE>>NS WEVINFO
IOLIT' AED D PSI T
.HE OON.ST
HT N
WR ,H.INNGN
FIIFTHNADANFFLAITTRN ANEW A,TTEO
N A,BA U TISIAV  PEIN S YE
AASERGRE LAT P AOLATHUT MFOPO C
T, YHEOCY SRENT BY
K PO F ENIMET M  TNSS
ATAT HOT RB.SO, WEOSTENETH ITHNA
LISILFEIA I
DEALISMAATOOIN KS  BOU
REENCOEREHRTTHTILIE INHAIB T A T
TER
OFSIRNTWATOINS.EROSERSOF OEN.S O
IHESO. PNHEATIBEYAR R NT LTT I
BY TUT TRE
INENEVE C R SUTLE HETHHIENNGAHIE
NNY DNIOLE
epANACU.TE.HERE
S  M T
G.LS,LAEMAYES  TEYS OTS R TSOMAW
ZEA
SUMEOVONESTHHE AIM OTKIAT S
AR C WUT ESO  BNKLLTYRONAF  TL L
ENHE TASTHTTCAte
A O
ALLTN,INEYY'AL SEDEL
LL
GEOA SERPODOUTLTHHE OATTL
SEHATATNAPIr:TT N  BCA I
G SREIS M S TYED COUTILIHOE
NS WRE
AE  O CIO HHAT'
KTITATHACEE
NOCLACDNSAYYN YPYWOCA 5AMCHFOTNI
ULTTPRIBITATPO MAFOUN.AVTOD